this bus has become a nightly feature on
the brussels landscape but there are no
passengers on board instead its
transporting the voices of families and
friends to loved ones they cannot be
with a grandmother emotional as a
recording from her grandchildren is
broadcast in the street outside her home
I'm allowed a shortcut he's a few
streets on and a child his birthday
wishes from his cousins who cannot join
him because of the lockdown the voices
of Brussels bus designed to keep people
connected people are very enthusiasts
when they see a commerce and it's a very
intensive message that they hear they're
there they're people speaking to a bus
it's a positive reaction of the people
the initiative is a response to weeks of
restriction on people's movement and
contact to slow the spread of codes most
of the lockdown is set to continue for
weeks yet but there are signs this city
is opening up the queue outside this
gardening and hardware store built early
on the first day the doors opened in a
month with kovat infection rates slowing
the government is taking tentative steps
to ease restrictions and customers are
grateful for the chance to get out I
think it's good that people can have
some things to do at home whether it's
in the garden or or doing some
construction will be good too to keep
the spirits up and to make sure that
people can still continue the next few
weeks if necessary at home if there are
the right measures taken there's no
difference between going to buy some
foods we're going to buy some of their
stuff after all people have to keep
themselves busy social distancing
measures were enforced as Brussels
followed other European nations in
easing some restrictions as infection
rates low
Denmark reopened primary schools this
week children and parents grateful badly
hit Italy has reopened children's
clothing stores and book shops and this
week Germany will allow non-essential
shops up to 800 meter square to start
trading again but gatherings of more
than two people outside a family will be
restricted the worry of course will be
that lifting measures could undo
progress made with slowing the spread of
kovat depending on what happens there
are no guarantees tougher measures won't
have to be implemented again Michele
preferred Sky News Brussels